what's up everyone uh welcome back to
the collider interviews YouTube channel
for a brand new chat with one of my
favorites Jennifer reader
holy [__] right up top perpetrator
something else it is so uniquely you and
that just fills my genre loving heart so
much so congratulations well thank you
Perry and honestly your your opinion
means so much to me I feel like you are
such a smart
cinephile and you know feeling seen by
you is uh I you know I'm not taking it
for granted that means the world to me
to hear that I pre I I deeply deeply
love this craft in general but genre
storytelling is one of my absolute
favorites and your voice in that space
is something that I think gives it lots
of Hope for the future to dig to start
digging into this uh this story here I
got two pretty big script questions to
start first when you were writing this
did you have a break story moment a
particular idea that you came up with
that you felt kind of pulled everything
together and made you say to yourself
like the idea is Rock Solid now and we
should go on it yeah I mean the biggest
the the biggest
um sort of question question and hurdle
was what would her shape-shifting be and
you know I had been I was writing
writing writing and I still had this
giant Gap I knew that I didn't want her
to be a werewolf or um a vampire I knew
that I didn't want her to turn into to
an animal I mean that is like the only
question and yet the biggest question
which remained a question for a long
time and when I started thinking about
very in a very unrelated way the power
of empathy
um and
and not and then extending that to the
idea of a kind of magical empathy or
empaths you know who really feel whether
it really works or not you know feel
um that they can absorb someone else's
feelings and energy and and you know in
a kind of girl superhero way I thought
well that could be really productive for
her if she gets to absorb it and then
sort of give all of that back to
somebody in that kind of playground way
like whatever you know you say bounces
off me and sticks back onto you kind of
a thing
um and then also very coincidentally you
know there was this moment where I
thought okay super empathy could really
work especially if I think of it um as a
way to kind of like flip the script on
the idea of the overly emotional woman
and how that becomes her superpower
um
and I had I was very coincidentally I
was watching all of these you know back
episodes of The Twilight Zone and there
was one
um you know where this guy depending on
the kind of way he angled his hat or
what the light was could be mistaken for
someone totally different and you know
in that moment I thought oh God you know
wouldn't I love to to be able to do that
you know I mean invisibility is cool but
you know to be able to sort of be one
person right before you walk into the
room and then be somebody completely
different when you walked into the room
and so I thought okay well that makes
perfect sense that was that moment where
I thought well if she has she has this
her empathy is so supercharged that she
can really look like someone else
um and especially when I you know when I
thought about the reveal of like when
the mother appears and how
um how much more complicated that could
be one person one particular kind of
person living as another particular kind
of person and how even culturally and
allegorically that could feel
um relevant to conversations around race
and gender so I mean it was like the
biggest question of the film and once I
figured out that that I could do it in a
way that would work at least for me then
you know that felt like okay let's we
got it let's go it's such a brilliant
way to tackle that idea and those kinds
of experiences because one of the one of
the main reasons why genre is my
favorite form of Storytelling is because
I find it easier to process difficult
human truths versus like out of this
world scenarios like that and basically
turning empathy into a superpower is
something that I it really deeply spoke
to me oh great I mean and that's and I
feel like that's what I what I what I
would hope and I think that there are
um you know sort of touring around with
it so far in the kind of limited good
sort of festival and other kind of
one-off screenings
having even a lot of teenagers in the
audience a lot of like queer teenagers
trans teenagers who kind of come up to
me afterwards and are like yeah I feel I
feel seen and validated and and you know
even ones who are not who sort of went
into the experience not necessarily a
genre a genre super fans and we're a
little like I could you know I get
scared in horror movies and I was like
there's there's a couple little jump
scares but it's not that you know it's I
think it's going to hit you in a deeper
way and having that response
um from those actual folks and you know
others as well has been really
meaningful and I've never
quite sure if I can if I can pull pull
it off
um at the end of the day but I am also
not interested in doing anything less
than sort of taking some big risks and
and sort of seeing if it seeing if it
works if you're not taking big risks
what's the point what are you doing what
are you doing with your wife I want to
get into the green light process a
little and I love formatting a question
like this this particular way but after
the success and how well received knife
uh knives and skin was what would you
what would you say is maybe the biggest
misconception about following up a hit
first feature like that with another
film or at least one in this case that
you're both writing and directing a big
misconception about what happens after
that but then I also want to know
something about the reception to knives
and skin that actually helped get this
movie made and made the way that you
wanted yeah that's a great question
because I you know I mean I think from
the outside
uh the idea that you've had
um you know a successful feature film
that launched out of a great Festival
that had a nice theatrical run that got
some great press blah blah blah that it
would be a no-brainer that you would
just
um you know every phone call every knock
at the door would be people just dying
to help you make your next film and
that's not necessarily the case or that
has not been the case for me and I think
sadly it's not always the case for a lot
of
um women writers and directors that some
amazing least successful you know women
writers and directors sort of start over
with every new film
especially in the sense that if you're
if you are taking some risks
um that you have to convince the
potential green lighters that you can
and will do exactly what you say you can
and will do with all of the money that
they are you know prepared to to give
you and you know trust weird women I say
that especially on the heels of of you
know the success of of Barbie and you
know I loved your interview with with
Greta and
um and Margo about all of the issues
that they were having it was just
endless issues there wasn't one all of
them were issues and knocking like
chipping away at all of that doubt and
chipping away at at all of those
potential no's can be exhausting but you
either do it or you just quit and hope
that Dunkin Donuts is hiring and you
know I I'm not a baker at all so you
know my only option is to is to sort of
stay in the room and
um keep keep can keep you know the story
going that says like I know exactly how
to do this and I know exactly how to
make the days and to stay on budget and
I know exactly how to get the cast that
you think is gonna you know make this
really special and I know exactly how
I'm going to choreograph a fight in a
giant you know well of blood uh you know
etc
etc etc
um that starting over can can you know
it can be exhausting but I know other
women do it and you you either do it or
you don't and so
um and I was happy that you know so
happy to work with shutter again I mean
I think that that they um you know and
and I talked to a lot of of other
companies who who were interested in in
in partnering for financing for this
film and and some of them kind of
couldn't get around it I mean for some
of them they understood that genre you
know is hot and there's a lot you know
women in genre is hot and so they kind
of wanted to to sort of get on that
train and yet at the end of the day
couldn't couldn't make that leap you
know and I hope that they're regretting
it so much right now
um but you know Sam and Emily from
shutter who I had worked with previously
who you know who knew exactly uh who I
am and my potential and you know were
let's like okay you know like we we
trust you I mean let's let's get ready
to you know Play and play and get weird
which is exactly what all the my amazing
cast did also you know they really
signed themselves up
um for uh as weird as you can get and
nobody you know looked looked back your
cast in this is something else I want to
focus of course on on Kaya first here
when you are casting that kind of role
what do you look for in an actor that
that you might have lead your Ensemble
that doesn't just signal to you like
yeah she can nail the sides that I'm
giving her but she could go a hundred
and ten percent in you know almost every
single scene of this entire film right
so I mean you know I had seen her in a
very small but memorable role in maravis
town and knew that she was really
compelling in front of the camera you
know I don't know who saw that series
and wasn't just like oh who's that DJ
you know I mean so I knew that she had
to be someone who was really captivating
in front of the
um in front of the camera not just not
to you know sound like a gross director
but I really knew that she
um physically was would be really
captivating in front of the camera
and then when I spoke to her
the thing that she said to me that none
of the other young actresses that I
spoke to said to me
she
um
said that as a young woman of color
multiracial queer
that
um she really understood Johnny's
transformation as being much more uh
like um metaphorical for a
multi-faceted identity and for the
Johnny's transformation in Johnny's
transformation that there is a kind of
nuanced code switching and that she
really understood sort of who she has to
be in different you know with her family
with her friends maybe in an audition
that she really understood in her own
skin who Johnny was in terms of her
ability to sort of you know um even
before and after her transition to
um to sort of try on news new try on her
own new skins and no one else had said
it like that and I didn't set out to
necessarily make that a huge draw for
um the actor but I knew absolutely that
then Kaya would be able to you know show
up every day because she was on set
every day she's in every scene and that
um she would own that role not simply be
able to do it yeah because she's a good
actor and she was interested in being
the lead that it was it was important to
her at her core it's not easy to hit
every single one of those layers you
just mentioned and still make a
character feel like the same person make
them feel cohesive but that is something
she does in this exceptionally well I do
want to ask you about working with her
as a collaborator because when I walk
away from a movie like this I look at
her and I'm like that right there is
someone that more filmmakers should cast
as their lead so what is something about
working with her as a collaborator and
the lead of your film that you're
excited for more directors to get to
experience when they work with her in
the future I mean she's
um you know she is absolutely a trooper
she comes from
um a theater background you know which
I'm very at work I love working with
theater people because they are they
have endurance you know this is Kaya is
a beautiful young woman but she
um is you know she puts the grind in and
she puts the sweat in and she is uh
absolutely delightful and friendly and
open and trusting you know so for
whether it's a film like this or it's
something that is more grounded in in um
in reality
you know an actor has to trust their
their director and she uh she she
trusted me and that that
um you know back and forth if you don't
have that then you have nothing and I
felt that from Alicia I felt that from
Christopher Lowell I felt that from all
of the amazing you know supporting
actors I mean and that's a huge
responsibility you know I mean walking
on set is a huge responsibility you know
over and over again because if something
goes wrong everyone is like looks at you
um if things go right that's the
Assumption you know no one gives you a
pat on the back for doing what you said
you were going to do
um but with the actors especially if
you're asking them to be vulnerable
um to be weird to be gross then there
has to have there has to be that level
of trust and Kaya let me let you know
Kaya let me let her be beautiful and
funny and weird and gross I have the
lipstick scene like you would think with
all the genre movies I've watched
something like that wouldn't bother me
but the idea of actually eating lipstick
just like it literally turns my stomach
thinking about it oh absolutely and
thankfully we had an amazing props
Wrangler who made some delicious kind of
gluten-free vegan you know edible
lipstick you know that I was not willing
to try myself I have to say you know I
made one movie back in the day about
eating eyeballs and I did indeed try the
fake eyeball at a point I cherish that
experience because you just mentioned
Alicia I'll go to her next I am curious
the answer to this might be no but I was
wondering if you two ever discussed
what's drawing her to genres
storytelling most now because obviously
I grew up totally obsessed with clueless
but now I'm obsessed with movie she's in
like like this of course also the
killing of a sacred deer and the lodge
that I've watched more times than I can
count so did the two of you ever talk
about what's drawing her to genre
storytelling now more than ever yes and
the the answer I mean I kind of
suspected what the answer would be and
she
confirmed it those you know stories like
perpetrator and certainly like killing
of a sacred deer and even you know the
lodge and especially her part you know
in the lodge which is gnarly it's a
small role but I was like whoa whoa oh
God what just happened I have to watch
that again
um it they are they are authentic but
very complex real representations of an
experience of a woman that is that is uh
sadly kind of rare in so many films it
seems to me and she still is in her real
life
um this you know this kind of up talky
Southern California blonde gorgeous you
know surf hair
um and yet she's so smart and she has
such an interesting perspective on the
world she's a mother she's an activist
and she knows in her own skin that she
deserves to play roles that are complex
even if they are a little gnarly and
bloody even if the character isn't
traditionally
you know beautiful I mean she is an
attractive woman still super attractive
and and yet she also understands the
value of playing somebody who for whom
Matt is not there
um you know Youth and beauty is not
their accomplishment there's something a
lot more
um a lot more rich and complicated so
and I wrote her I had to write her this
long letter you know in anticipation of
sending the script to her and I talked
to her in the letter you know I talked
about how meaningful it would be to
um you know to cast her as this really
powerful complicated matriarch of a
shape-shifting family who's a mentor to
an iconic teen knowing that in her own
provenance she was introduced to us as
an iconic teen in a role that she
totally still you know Embraces I mean
we had the the amazing coincidental you
know Fortune of um screening perpetrator
in Berlin the Friday after her Super
Bowl ad
um appeared where she kind of reprises
the share Horowitz role for an ad for I
think it's Rakuten and you know it was
it was great to have that kind of to
sort of be reminded of of who she was
that we were all remembered who you know
how we how we met her you know and then
to to sort of pattern her in perpetrator
after very specifically after
um the Catherine denove character in The
Hunger
you know so she's healed there's there's
a lot of Miriam Blaylock in my Hildy or
a lot of that kind of Tippy Headroom Kim
Novak cool hitchcocky and blonde the
structured hair the sort of like
buttoned up outfits I mean Hildy had to
be restrained and Alicia landed and came
to set and really wanted to
um to stylize Hildy even in her own
acting you know she lowered the register
of her voice she spoke more slowly you
know she has these kind of twinkling
eyes but she was able to kind of deaden
them a little you know in this way that
was also had this
um you know an eerie an eeriness about
you know who she was and what exactly
Hildy has experienced over her lifetime
and that can only happen if you've got a
really smart actor who is who's looking
for roles that are that are complicated
and challenging one of the scenes that
impressed me the most fru from an acting
standpoint and also writing is that
exposition heavy scene right smack in
the middle of the movie where Hildy
answers all of Johnny's questions or
tries to the best of her ability it just
feels like those kinds of Big explainer
scenes could run the risk of killing the
illusion or even though the momentum of
a movie but I don't know that scene just
fell to me like it was powered with so
much Natural Curiosity and warmth and I
do think that comes from the script but
it's also in the way she delivers those
lines and man that is like a make or
break type of delivery right there oh
100 and it was even longer I mean we
took some parts out but you know it's
that moment where I knew because her
shape shifting is is um you know the
forevering aspect is is a little more
nuanced than just her turning into a
werewolf for instance which I you know
nothing against werewolves love
werewolves
um but right getting a getting a kind of
monologue like that where you have to
deliver some expository information and
and I and yet I still wanted to um to
keep the keep it a little mysterious and
and po poetic because I just feel like
Hildy wouldn't would not it would be
antithetical for hilly to explain it in
a very pedestrian kind of clunky way you
know she has to have these you know a
possession in Reverse where women
feeling all the feelings you know period
and you know to have these moments of um
of where an audience has to sit and and
think about what what that means exactly
and you know working with Alicia herself
me she did so much prep leading up to it
she would call me or text me with
questions about
um you know about a line for instance
like possession in Reverse you know she
would say you know she thought about it
a lot and sometimes she would ask me
that a question and just as I was
getting ready to answer it she would say
oh never mind we're making art you know
and just was like okay I have I have an
answer I can answer that question but
was also she was like I can I'm gonna go
back and and figure this out for myself
or understand and trust you and that art
is important for that sake and that we
don't have to make something that feels
so
um basic that we can make these kind of
um you know weird moves which is why I
find you know working in the genre
realm so uh so productive because I can
lean into what I do best what I think I
do best which is the kind of visual
storytelling and
um I can lean into the unexpected or the
allegorical and I know that that you
know genre fans are like down to go
there and to and to kind of fill in some
of the gaps and to not
um I mean having said that I don't I
don't set out to make gaps you know
that's not sort of like I want the story
to to make sense and I want an audience
to feel satisfied I know there's lots of
people who are not at all satisfied with
the moves I make which is totally fine
um but I but I think the the the cast of
this film at some level also are all
kind of artists at heart you know I mean
certainly you know I mean Alicia having
you know been an actor for as long as
she is I mean it's it's in her and
Christopher Lowell who is just like also
kind of number one weirdo I mean his
Instagram is is full of his own
photographs which are incredible I mean
he's he's a great actor but he really is
someone who in his own
um you know in in his in his real life
is someone who just appreciates
um you know Art For Art's Sake you get
that vibe from him and many of the
others that are in this movie and it
doesn't surprise me also to see a lot of
collaborators from something like knives
and skin returns I feel like when you
find those people you hold tight to them
oh yeah absolutely I could keep you here
all day talking about this movie I'm not
allowed to so I'm going to ask one more
question that kind of leans into some of
what you were just uh what you were just
referring to I love that you preserve
the mystery and you don't spell
everything out here kind of invites a
viewer to you know apply their own
experience and their thinking to this
scenario so given the fact that this
film has been on the festival circuit
for quite a while it's not coming out
for everyone to see until September 1st
but people have seen it is there any
particular reaction that someone had to
the movie that you know pleasantly
surprised you you or maybe even inspired
you to rethink something in your own
movie or perhaps appreciate it more well
the biggest surprise in both like
audience q and A's and a lot of the
press is the reaction to the blood and I
did not I really didn't set out to make
this blood-soaked film I mean I didn't
realize I mean look I would walk on to
set and there would be five five gallon
you know Buckets of Blood and I was like
yeah of course I don't know that we'll
use all of that today but in the next
couple of days for sure and and um I
just wanted to make a film that
authentically felt like what oftentimes
my own experience as a person with the
uterus you know has you know felt with
blood and that I wanted to kind of like
make blood its own character and give
blood its own kind of agency and and
Aura because I think that we still also
live in a culture where you know women
bleeding is at best a secret at worst
you know a shame
and so uh I I set out to to to make a
film that felt like uh it was giving
it's it was giving blood its comeuppance
um and and what's been surprising is
like the the response is like wow that's
the bloodiest film I've ever seen and
I'm like that's the bloodiest film
you've ever seen okay I mean it is blood
so that was a surprise but at the same
time I'm like okay I've made the
bloodiest film that at least that person
has ever seen I mean it might not be the
bloodiest film I've ever seen but I
think it's uh it's maybe one of the
movies where blood made a unique
impression more so than ever were you
actually capture like a multitude of
layers of blood in addition to your
human characters here yeah and we
definitely had like different uh you
know different kind of different kinds
of blood on set depending on in my mind
what the what the origin of that of that
of that blood was and and certainly our
blood makers in the art Department were
um you know they had to keep their kind
of gag reflex
um under control you know I didn't
realize how how much like a vat of of a
very fake theatrical blood could really
kick in some kind of visceral reaction
or that again magicians in that
particular Department Jennifer I must
let you go I will say congratulations
please keep making movies your way I
love them to everybody out there
perpetrator is streaming on shutter and
it's also in Select theaters on
September 1st do not miss it that's
fairy thanks collider always love
talking to you